Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at why,
when stating the time, it's common to add
"o'clock".
The practice of saying “o’clock” is
simply a remnant of times when clocks weren’t
very prevalent and people told time by various
means, depending on where they were and what
references were available.
Generally, of course, the Sun was used as
a reference point, with solar time being slightly
different than clock time.
Clocks divide the time evenly, whereas, by
solar time, hour lengths vary somewhat based
on a variety of factors, like what season
it is.
Thus, to distinguish the fact that one was
referencing a clock’s time, rather than
something like a sundial, as early as the
fourteenth century one would say something
like, “It is six of the clock,” which
later got slurred down to “six o’clock”
sometime around the sixteenth or seventeenth
centuries.
In those centuries, it was also somewhat common
to just drop the “o’” altogether and
just say something like “six clock.”
Using the form of “o’clock” particularly
increased in popularity around the eighteenth
century when it became common to do a similar
slurring in the names of many things such
as “Will-o’-the wisp” from “Will of
the wisp” (stemming from a legend of an
evil blacksmith named Will Smith, with “wisp”
meaning “torch”) and “Jack-o’-lantern”
from “Jack of the lantern” (which originally
just meant “man of the lantern” with “Jack,”
at the time, being the generic “any man”
name.
Later, either this or the Irish legend of
“Stingy Jack” got this name transferred
to referring to carved pumpkins with lit candles
inside).
While today with clocks being ubiquitous and
few people, if anybody, telling direct time
by the Sun, it isn’t necessary in most cases
to specify we are referencing time from clocks,
but the practice of saying “o’clock”
has stuck around anyway.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below
and consider sharing it with anyone you think
might be interested.
And if you're new to the channel, don't forget
to subscribe for many more videos like this.
Finally, if you've got something you've always
wondered about that you'd like us to do a
deep dive on, don't hesistate to ask in the
comments below.
Thanks for watching.